18:45 in North America looks like this
it was divided between the United States
the Republic of Mexico the British
Empire and finally the Republic of Texas
in 1846 after a decade of indecision the
United States annexed Texas which upset
the Mexicans this was because Texas had
itself seceded from Mexico and the two
also claimed the same land which now
meant that the claims of Texas were the
claims of the USA President James K Polk
sent troops to the disputed Mexican US
border and as he had hoped fighting
broke out which meant war Mexico
surrendered after the u.s. occupied its
capital Mexico City in the subsequent
1848 peace treaty of Guadalupe Hidalgo
Mexico ceded all of this territory in
the same year the United States and
Britain came to an agreement over the
disputed northern territories and
settled on this so within only four
years the United States had grown from
this to this and it was spurred on by
the idea of manifest destiny this was
the argument that the United States was
willed by God and destined to spread
westward and control all of this
territory before making it fundamentally
American all of this new territory was
not necessarily a good thing though so
America at this point was economically
socially and politically divided North
versus South urban versus rural slave
state versus free state and federal
versus state government the North was
much more urbanized industrialized and
for the most part had outlawed the
practice of slavery many in the North
sources of barbaric practice a sentiment
reinforced by its high rate of European
migration whom for the most part came
from nations which had already outlawed
its practice the South was much more
rural with a greater focus on labor
intensive agriculture which meant that
slavery was economically valuable and
had to become a fact of life there those
who held slaves there also believed that
slavery was simply the natural order of
things
the reason that the US had previously
hesitated on the annexation of Texas was
due to these internal tensions over
slavery in the US Senate each state held
the same number of senators and within
the Senate there was a balance between
the states which allowed slavery in
those which had abolished it Texas was a
slave state and so the balance was upset
which led to fist debates over what
should happen with the new territories
and how they can be used to address this
imbalance there were many in the u.s.
who were fiercely opposed to slavery and
thus didn't want any more slave states
in the Union one example was David
Wilmot who tabled the Wilmot Proviso
which was supposed to ban any
territories acquired from Mexico from
permitting slavery but he got nowhere on
the opposite side senator Jefferson
Davis of Mississippi argued that the new
territory should be comprised of slave
state and that furthermore they should
annex Cuba slightly more
middle-of-the-road was Stephen Douglas
who argued for what was called popular
sovereignty meaning that new states
should be allowed to decide for
themselves these arguments culminated in
the compromise of 1850 which gave
statehood to California as a free state
allowed the New Territories in the south
to decide whether or not they wanted to
allow slavery and importantly it
implemented a new and very controversial
Fugitive Slave Law this required anyone
in any state even if a had abolished
slavery to Hambach escaped slaves to
their masters what this meant was that
the North had to actively play a role in
maintaining slavery which was not
something that they could abide also as
a side note in 1853 the US purchased
this land of her Mexico thus completing
its modern-day contiguous borders
throughout the 1850s anti-slavery
sentiment called abolitionism grew
throughout the north with men like New
York Governor and later Senator William
Seward in the much more extreme John
Brown being outspoken critics of slavery
in 1854 the kansas-nebraska Act opened
up large-scale settlement of migration
to those states whose position on
slavery would be decided by popular
sovereignty
thus proponents and opponents to slavery
flooded into Kansas to aid their side in
the debate this resulted in what is
known as Bleeding Kansas where by both
sides they're attacked and sometimes
killed the other further raising
tensions in the nation 1856 or the
pro-slavery incumbent President James
Buchanan of the Democratic Party run for
re-election he won but this election is
important because he ran against a
brand-new party the anti-slavery
Republican Party which for the most part
dominated in the north the next year
1857 saw a very important ruling by the
Supreme Court in what's called the Dred
Scott case this was where Dred Scott a
slave was taken by his master to
Illinois a free state Scott argued that
being in a free statement that he was by
law free the court wrote no and further
declared that black people were not
intended to be US citizens at all and by
extension they had no rights worth
protecting needless to say this was a
very controversial ruling and further
raise tensions between Pro and
anti-slavery factions 1858 so the
Republicans attempt a challenge Stephen
Douglas for his seat by putting some
chap could Abraham Lincoln up against
him Douglass defeated Lincoln but both
had taken part in his series of debate
which has made Lincoln well known across
the country and cemented him as a
leading abolitionist fortunately after
this tensions between the north and the
south between Pro and anti-slavery
factions died down and by died down I
mean got considerably worse the fear
abolitionist John Brown launched a raid
on Harpers Ferry Arsenal this was
supposed to cease weapons from the
government and give them to slaves to
incite revolt it didn't work Brown was
defeated captured and later hanged both
North and South were now in a state of
mutual hatred and there was talk in the
south of secession in 1860 things got
worse the Republicans nominated Abraham
Lincoln as their presidential candidate
in the Democratic Party was divided in
the south they nominated current vice
president John Breckinridge and in the
north they chose Stephen Douglas the
vote was split Lincoln won and since
Lincoln was an abolitionist many in the
South feared what he would do next
Lincoln was actually pretty moderate and
pledged not to interfere with slavery in
existing state but the damage was
already done before Lincoln had even
taken office South Carolina had declared
itself to have seceded from the United
States within a couple of months these
states had joined them this also
included Texas who had been in the Union
for like five minutes at this point
these states then went on to form the
Confederate States of America under the
presidency of Jefferson Davis during the
early months of 1861 South Carolina had
demanded that since they were
independent federal troops should
evacuate the federal government refused
to maintain their garrison at Fort
Sumter on April the 12th 1861 the
Confederate States Navy were part of the
fortune captured the next day thereby
beginning the American Civil War by July
these states had also joined the
Confederacy and thus will also award the
United States so before discussing the
war itself it's important to discuss how
both sides saw the conflict both sides
referred to the Declaration of
Independence to justify their fight the
north also called the Union cited the
all men are created equal bit whereas
the Confederacy focused on the right to
alter or abolish on just government's
bit the Union claimed that slavery
helped the entire nation back and
prevented the south from industrializing
and modernizing they also argued that
owning another human being was you know
wrong the Confederacy claimed that the
north was barely even American anymore
with all those immigrants there and so
it wasn't for those who lived there to
tell them what to do they also argued
that it was their right to form a better
Union since as far as they were
concerned the current Union did nothing
to protect their enshrined rights to
property that property being slaves so
in terms of strengths and weaknesses the
Union held massive advantages it was
more industrialized had many more miles
of railways and telegraph lines and had
a much larger economy it also had a
population of 22 million versus the
south 9 million of which three and a
half million were slave
and thus not likely to fight all of
these things considered it would seem
inevitable that the Union would crush
the Confederacy quickly but when the two
sides first clashed at the First Battle
of Bull Run
the Confederates won this was because
they had many competent generals the
most notable of course being robert e
lee the confederacy generally speaking
also had much higher morale because it's
much easy to convince men to fight for
the homeland than it is to get them to
fight for concepts such as Union and
abolitionism the Confederacy also hoped
to gain foreign support to which it
primarily turned to Britain Britain was
reliant on southern cotton imports and
when the Union blockaded the South it
meant the Britain's textile industry was
severely disrupted so in late 1861 when
the Union captured Confederate delegates
on the way to Britain in what is called
the Trent affair the British were
furious since it wasn't for the u.s. to
dictate who Britain could speak to
Britain postured but after Lincoln
released the diplomats tensions called
and Britain then told said diplomats
that they were on their own it was clear
that the war would not be over quickly
in 1862 played host to two important
battles the first was the naval clash
here at the Battle of Hampton Roads
which is important because it was the
first crush of ironclad warship the USS
Monitor and the CSS Virginia the
Confederates had hoped to break the
naval blockade but failed after this
came the Battle of Antietam which
despite the Union having twice as many
men was a stalemate but given that the
Union didn't lose this battle ax gave
Lincoln the opportunity to issue a
warning that unless the Confederate
states surrendered by the end of the
year he would abolish slavery the
Confederacy of course did not do that
and on the 1st of January 1863 Lincoln
issued the Emancipation Proclamation
which abolished slavery throughout the
states of the Confederacy but not in
those still in the Union which
incidentally now included West Virginia
which had itself split from Virginia
Lincoln couldn't unilaterally abolish
slavery everywhere since he needed the
permission of the states to do so since
the South was in revolt they didn't have
any legislators whom the Union
recognized so Lincoln could do it on his
own the Emancipation did shift the
framing of the war from one of
maintaining the Union to one of ending
slavery
this made Britain and France his office
of mediation that hypocritical since
they had already abolished slavery
themselves so 1863 also saw the war's
most famous battle the Battle of
Gettysburg which saw Lee attempt to
bring the horrors of war to the north
but he was defeated and subsequently ran
away this battle was seen as a bit of a
turning point and when Lincoln won
re-election the next year in a platform
of I'm going to crush them it became
clear that only total victory would do
the Union blockade was taking its toll
on the
soon after the loss of Atlanta to
General William Sherman it became clear
that the Confederacy was going to lose
and on April the 9th 1865 at the
Appomattox Courthouse General Lee
surrendered to grant effectively ending
the Civil War Jefferson Davis was soon
after captured the South was occupied in
the Union now had the difficult job of
repairing the damage
Lincoln was presumably very happy with
this victory but wouldn't have long to
enjoy it Lincoln took the time to go to
the theater and a man could John Wilkes
Booth a Confederate sympathizer took the
time to kill him Andrew Johnson
Lincoln's successor as president now had
to create a piece that could heal a
broken nation 1865 saw the passage of
the 13th amendment which abolished
slavery throughout the United States the
primary cause of the Civil War was done
away with and so began the process of
healing a nation but of course that
would take a long long time I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching and a special thanks to James
Bissonnette Thomas guest Strich Adam
Harvey and Winston K wood if you'd like
to learn more about the American Civil
War there are some book recommendations
in the description below
you